Good Morning, Hank! It's Tuesday!
So, before meeting a lot of Nerdfighters last night in single "n", double "n", single "t" Cincinnati,
I was here, in the Miami Whitewater Forest,
where the autumn leaves are falling, and
the squirrels are appropriately afraid of humans,
and while walking alone through the forest,
I thought to myself,
I don't really wanna make a "Thoughts from Places"
video today while I'm here,
I just wanna go on a freaking walk without
videotaping every single thing I do.
So it's Question Tuesday, the day I answer
real questions from real Nerdfighters,
let's get right to it!
What are you going to be for Halloween?
I'm gonna be a 35 year old man.
Why is legislation to kill the penny being
held up in Congress?
Because if the current Congress were
actually and physically on fire,
they couldn't pass a Throw Water on Congress Act.
Who is your OTP?
Peanut butter and honey,
their OTP name is Pea-bunny.
What does the raven symbolize in that
Edgar Allen Poe poem?
Death.
A good rule of thumb is that if you see something that
looks like it might be a symbol in a work
by Edgar Allen Poe, it's death.
What's something you've always wanted to microwave?
Oh, peeps!
Hot plate,
disgusting,
somewhat burnt,
microwaved peeps.
To go with my lunch of apples.
Pancakes, or pancakes?
Pancakes! I mean, I realize this is stating the obvious,
but they are cakes that you can cook in a pan!
It's an everyday miracle!
Would you rearrange the alphabet if you could?
Yeah, totally.
I'd be so much better at alphabetizing if instead of
having to sing the ABC song every freaking time,
I could just say Big Fjords Vex Quick Waltz Nymph.
Sure, we'd then have two a's, but we need two a's!
Best book I've never heard of?
The Blood of the Lamb by Peter de Vries
which inspired large parts of An Imperial Affliction
by Peter van Houten.
Can you draw a platypus?
Yes. Yes, I can.
When is that box set thing coming out?
That box set thing comes out on October 25th
and there's a limited edition that have both The Fault in
Our Stars and Looking for Alaska signed,
link in the doobly-doo.
Did you ever feel slightly attracted to Augustus Waters
while writing The Fault in Our Stars?
No! A little bit.
Why does the number pi never end?
I don't know, it's totally irrational.
Velociraptor or Brontosaurus?
I don't know, let's call an expert.
(To Henry) Hey, Henry, do you like brontosaurus
or velociraptor better?
Henry: Velociraptor!
John: You like velociraptors better?
Henry: Yeah!
John: Velociraptors.
In what situation is it appropriate to
use the acronym YOLO?
Really in any situation where you're acting out
of an abundance of caution,
for instance, "I think I'll obey the speed limit today, YOLO"
or "I'm gonna pass up this opportunity to go skydiving because YOLO".
Do you think you'd jump from space?
No, I wouldn't jump from table.
Favorite statue?
This guy.
Least favorite statue?
This guy
Favorite president?
James K. Polk, Napoleon of the Stump
Did Barack Obama's tumblr really post Hank's voting video?
No! Wait, really? Really?
Hank, you are on the President's tumblr!
Also, the President has a tumblr.
Why don't any of the main characters in
your books have siblings?
Ahh, it's just my little way of telling Hank that
he doesn't exist in my narrative imagination.
Wait, who the eff is Hank?
Hank is an American folk rock band originally
formed in Claremont, California.
Hey, what's your favorite part of Atlas Shrugged?
No.
Hey, what have you learned from teaching
world history for a year?
I've learned that humans generally get less
miserable when we collaborate
and that we get totally hosed when we choose
ideology over actual humans.
Hey, when will your next book come out?
I don't know, 2014, 2015? It's gonna be a while.
Gandalf or Dumbledore?
I'm hiding under the table so you people can't attack me,
but Gandalf.
Favorite period of history?
Wait for it... the Mongols.
All time five favorite John Greens?
Alright, in order,
Bald John Green, Other John Green,
the political science professor,
the mustachioed cavalry officer,
and the Bigfoot researcher known as
one of the four horsemen of Sasquatchery.
Will this be the last question?
Indeed it will.
Nerdfighters, thank you for all your great questions;
Hank, thank you for your brilliant video last week,
I will see you on Friday.